a dental laboratory in hale in eastern
germany
new terrain for claudio santosh he used
to work for the portuguese army
my contract is over so i have to look
for another opportunities and
when i saw this
i thought well
it's a good one
and i just grab it
he found the job via the mobile pro eu
programme as did katyaleti
she used to work in insurance but is now
also considering a future in dental
prosthetics
i worked with people and another area
and here i work
with different things
but
we have the same responsibility
and we need to be very focused
this is very nice
three portuguese interns are a welcome
addition to the busy team at the dental
prosthetics lab
former secretary liliana silva is now
taking dental imprints rather than
dictation
it's very different portuguese is more
relaxed
jobs and here is
everything is
really
certain you understand
yeah it's good
it's different
i like the way
deutsch people works
liliana is making impression trays
and she's made a big impression on her
boss who's casting an eye on the future
and her new full-time staff
she has a good aptitude for the job and
was working on patients after just three
weeks
i'm delighted
one significant obstacle however is the
language barrier and before even being
comfortable in day-to-day german the
interns have to master technical terms
such as bite plate
i'll write down the term like biz
chablone and she writes it in portuguese
then we practice saying it
right
that's much
liliana
better
lives in a communist era concrete
high-rise together with her family
she practices german with fellow
portuguese interns there are some 40 of
them in hala and with her daughter who's
a quick learner
the interns are paid around 800 euros a
month
enough for liliana herself to live on
but not her family as well
her husband has to stay home with erica
they told me that
she could come here
that
he ha
she have a kindergarten to go
but only in september so she stay at
home with my husband now
in september we'll see
the interns made advanced preparations
in portugal but the language courses
there weren't as productive as hoped
later rivals like claudio begin with
practically no german when i made the
interview i only know how to say my name
and
it was very good i have to speak in
english and in this part of germany
english isn't widely spoken
on the outskirts of the city we meet
other portuguese interns building a new
sports hall
they come from a variety of backgrounds
renaldo costa used to be a piano teacher
but he may be trading in music for a
career as an electrician
the job is different work is different
but
in this three months we have to to see
and then and then
we have to say if
if
i like it if
but
i enjoy it
building sites aren't everyone's dream
workplace but despite having seen one
intern quit the site supervisor is
optimistic
the language is a problem especially on
the technical terminology
but some are doing pretty well we'll
have to see whether it works out
the best way of learning both skills and
terminology is on the job
the four young portuguese interns here
will decide in the autumn whether they
feel up to doing a full apprenticeship
in german
this is they've got my respect they've
come to a new country without knowing
the language
all the people we have here have
relatively advanced high school
qualifications
because there's a shortage of skilled
tradesmen in hale the company is
offering free extra language tuition to
those who become trainees
budding dental technicians are also thin
on the ground in this region how are you
coming along
did you do this all by yourself
it looks very nice
all that it needs now is a number on it
is she confident they'll stay
yeah yes
they'll be committed to the
apprenticeship which can take another
three and a half years
i'm sure they'll want to complete that
successfully
and while they still miss portugal
they're eager to settle in here
we need to
talk with a lot of german people
to really understand the culture the way
of living and do the same
in a few months time they'll decide
whether halle will be their new home for
good